Now we had all the ingredients; we had purified microtubules
made from purified tubulin,
we had the membrane organelles,
we had the chemical energy source ATP, and now we can add them in
various combinations and see what might work to allow
this magical process of organelle transport to occur in the test tube.
We found that when we added organelles,
microtubules and ATP, surprisingly,
there was no movement.
But we found that the organelles themselves were not capable of moving
until we added this soluble protein fraction.
And finally we saw tremendous movement of these
organelles along the microtubules.
This was a really exciting moment.
I had been working essentially for four months to get these organelles to
undergo motility in a test tube,
just like in the native axon.
But the next experiment was even more surprising.
It was called a control experiment.
Essentially we wanted to make sure that what we thought we saw moving were in fact the
membrane organelles and not something else that might have been
coming along with the soluble protein fraction.
So the way to figure that out was just to mix everything again but leave out the
membrane organelles, just add together the microtubules,
the ATP and the soluble protein fraction. And we thought nothing would happen,
that we wouldn't see anything,
and then we can call it a night and go home.
But what happened was really mind-blowing.
We looked under the microscope and the microtubules,
which are these long biological polymers,
were sliding around,
crawling around like snakes on the glass surface.
That was something that we certainly didn't expect at all.
And in fact,
it even it took us a few minutes to even think about what was happening
here.
Why were these microtubules crawling along the glass surface? After we had
overcome our amazement and surprise by that result,
we then began to piece together in our head what might be happening.
Maybe that soluble protein fraction that contained some agent
that was causing the organelles to move actually contained the motor
itself.
So the soluble protein fraction had motors that were floating around
in it without the organelles and these motors
would also be able to stick onto the surface of this glass
slide,
grab hold of the microtubules and transport these microtubules along the
glass.
Think of a rock concert;
the singer jumps off the stage into the mosh pit,
and the people in the audience, who are stationary there, grab hold of the singer
and transport the rock star across.
We thought a very similar thing was happening there with the microtubules crawling on
glass.
The next day,
I was able extend those results to find that
we could get plastic beads, in the presence of this soluble
axoplasmamic protein fraction, also to move along microtubules.
And this is sometimes what happens in science,
you know,
you work really hard,
you don't get any results,
it gets frustrating,
you have to persevere.
And then one magical day,
everything really seems to come together and the
experiment is suddenly propelled much farther than you could have ever imagined.
And that's a little bit the nature of science.
It's when persistence counts for a lot,
one has to be prepared for the unexpected,
and one has to believe that one's experiment is going to work in the very
end.
And I think once one has that kind of experience,
one's also willing to persevere on a lot of other experiments later
in one's scientific career as well.